hey i'm kevin hi i'm stephanie hey i'm
lauren and today we're going to be
drawing a stranger based
only on their voice and self-description
that's going to be difficult
i am terrible at caricatures i'm worried
about making them look like me
you know like that just kind of happens
when you don't know
i'm the one who draws people looking
like me oh that's true
you kind of suck all that energy up so
[Music]
all right friends so please welcome our
stranger for today
their name is kelsey hi chelsea hey
kelsey
hey what's going on so kelsey where are
you joining us from today
i am tuning in from detroit michigan
motor city do they still call it motor
city did i just
date myself there no they still call it
motor city okay
hardcore so kelsey tell me have you ever
met any of us before
nope never i've never been to detroit so
the the odds of me having met her are
very slim
you have to come visit me sometime
kelsey okay so here's how it works
kelsey can't see our screens we can't
see each other's screens
so the only way we know what to draw is
by what kelsey tells us
and if you're going to play along at
home be sure to post and tag us on
instagram or twitter
at drawoffshow alright let's get started
okay so first things first kelsey so
none of us embarrass ourselves can you
please tell us your pronouns
and your ethnicity i'm mexican and
hungarian
and my pronouns are
she her princess
love it so princess kelsey
uh what celebrity would you say you most
often get compared to
oh shoot okay kylie jenner
um selena gomez and snooki
[Music]
interesting incredible
[Applause]
what a range what a range the snooki got
me by surprise
talk about the hair texture what's that
hair do
naturally it's super straight like the
straightest of straight
ever and it's super thick okay
uh so kelsey what do you do what's like
your your job your hobbies
i am a professional singer and dancer
for singing i perform and i do
a lot of legends shows so i travel with
different
elvis impersonators
and nail diamonds and all that fun stuff
i do like a lot of brenda lee connie
francis
patsy cline different legends yeah
for dancing um i specialize in tap
dancing
basically i run a tap company
here in detroit i run a tap company
in cleveland ohio but
i wanna kelsey i wanna go back to uh
the the impressions that you said that
you did
tell me those again uh brenda lee
connie francis patsy klein
okay so when you said that that
completely
changed my idea for my drawing
[Music]
uh so now i'm i'm i'm
scrambling to to switch things up do you
know who they are
a lot of people don't know who they are
come on have you seen my gray hair
i'm about to climb at least uh
i was just wondering if you had like a
favorite tour story or anything like
that
i got kidnapped one time what
did you like well it was in new york
um and basically our
um our driver was not a real
driver they were supposed to take us to
the airport
but then they didn't and then yeah
but i'm very persuasive and they let us
go so we're good
i'm i'm so glad you're safe though that
sounds crazy
yeah pretty crazy you mean like patsy
cline's
hit crazy oh shoot throwing out them
jokes so kelsey you have
told us that you are a performer but we
haven't heard you sing yet
so are you gonna give us a little taste
yeah
happy birthday to
you happy birthday
to you happy birthday
happy birthday
happy birthday to
you wow
you're really good thank you have you
ever been drawn before
yes i have been drawn before my favorite
story is i was performing as tap dancing
at like orchestra hall and it was like
this big show this girl was sitting in
the front row
so her view was kind of like from down
below
and uh she decided to
in the middle of the show like just
randomly
um got out some paper and decided to
draw my butt
so so i have a picture
of me from the behind from down below
i have it hanging up in my room
i mean you gotta hang something like
that up right
i was very flattered okay just need to
add a quick
thing of blush that is way too
dark oh wait blush oh okay
all right i can do that too and i put
way too much on
steph quick how do you do blush
so apples of the cheek just a nice
little swipe yeah no no no no
cheek like what brush are you using
oh you don't get to know that
this is so exciting
i'm it's it's nerve-wracking but
all right pens down let's send them to
each other
see what it do
[Music]
oh wow
[Music]
those are so cute it's adorable
pretty these are great stephanie's is
super cute thanks because it looks like
a barbie
it's like super pretty kevin super
accurate looks just like me
wow lauren i love the eyes
um i do have like pretty big eyes and i
have a million crowns
so there's that as well so
all right kelsey so moment of truth
you're gonna turn on your camera in a
second
but if you're playing along at home be
sure to pause and finish your drawing
so that way you don't see what she looks
like before you're done i'm nervous
okay we're all nervous yeah
all right kelsey so you're gonna turn on
your camera in three
two one
hey i'm kelsey hi chelsea
hi princess kelsey yes i think they're
all pretty accurate
right
i'm proud of us i think you can find it
this was a good match
this was so much fun well thanks to
kelsey for joining us and if you want a
better look at these drawings your
drawings and find out how you could be
possibly our next stranger be sure to
hit us up
on instagram and twitter at draw off
show kelsey
you want to tap dance us out yeah i'm
ready
[Music]
um i get compliments about my voice
all the time um but people say oh yes
sounds so high you sound like a little
kid you're like a chipmunk
and then when i sing it's super
low